♪ ♪ ♪
- Alors que la saison
ivals bat son plein
et à deux semaines des vacances
de la construction, le Québec
entre dans la septième vague
de la pandémie.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre, Santé
et Services sociaux du Québec
- On n'aime pas l'augmentation
des cas, mais elle est
encore sous contrôle.
Mais ce portant,
c'est de rester vigilants.
- Dans les deux dernières
semaines, le nombre de cas
a bondi de 69 %.
e plus de 1500 personnes
hospitalisées aux prises
avec la COVID, dont
43 aux soins intensifs.
Et 7300 travailleurs de la santé
sont absents du réseau.
Malgré tout, Québec refuse
de réinstaurer des mesures
sanitaires, comme le port
du masque dans les transports
en commun.
- On n'est plus rendus à obliger
des choses alors que les gens
savent très bien les risques;
il s'agit juste de les rappeler.
Et c'est ça qu'on fait
aujourd'hui.
Dre CAROLINE QUACH pédiatre,
microbiologiste-infectiologue
- Je pense que les choses
sont quand même relativementsous
mesures beaucoup plus sévères,
ça va amener aussi
une démotivation puis
une perte de confiance.
- Dans la rue, il y a peu
d'appétit pour un retour
à des mesures obligatoires.
- Moi, j'ai compris que
libre puis je trouve
ça une bonne chose aussi,
qu'on soit libres de le porter,
comme vous voyez, dans
les transports en commun.- J'aie
ça soit comme une
responsabilité individuelle.
- Pour réduire la propagation,
Québec tient à rappelerles règlr
ceux qui contractent la COVID.
Dès l'apparition des symptômes,
ils doivent rester à la maison
pendant cinq jours puis sort
de chez eux uniquement si c'est
essentiel pendant les cinq jours
suivants, en portant le masque.
Dr LUC BOILEAU, directeur
national de santé publique du Qc
- On ne devrait pas aller
au resto, aller rencontrer
des amis, à part
si c'està distance,
on ne devrait pas aller
dans des spectacles.
- Le gouvernement lance
nouvel ap nouvel ap nouvel ap l
à la vaccination.
- On le sait qu'après cinq-six
mois, un six mois bien sonné,
baisse de l'immunité,
c'est comme ça!
- Un arbre décisionnel a été
publié par le ministère de
la Santé pour comprendre quand
obtenir une dose de rappel.
On encourage particulièrement
les 60 ans et plus
à le faire dès maintenant.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Prenez pas de chance, alle
chercher une dose de rappel si
ça fait plus de trois mois que
vous avez eu la dernière dose
ou que vous avez eu la COVID
- Même si la septième vague
s'amorce en ce moment,
Québec s'attend à une remontée
des cas cet automne avecle retot
les rassemblements qui se feront
davantage à l'intérieur
plutôt qu'à l'extérieur.